oui
le président de l'assemblée nationale
sans doute des locaux de ce journal
rencontre giscard schmitt avant le
sommet de copenhague ils ont beaucoup
parlé du dollar marée noire
volontaires patience la priorité c'est
le pompage du mazout du côté de
grossesse l'ex-président de la france
on n'avait pas vu ça depuis 30 ans un
reportage de jean-claude bonhomme
l'eau
messieurs bonsoir dents
quelques minutes dans quelques secondes
peut-être même en tout cas avant la
fin de ce journal
jacques chaban delmas se passe selon
toute vraisemblance retrouver un
fauteuil qu'il connaît bien
qu'il a occupé pendant dix ans les
qu'il avait quittée en 69 pour devenir
premier ministre
le fameux perchoir du palais bourbon à
la présidence de l'assemblée nationale
son élection ne se sera pas faite sans
douleur au premier tour le maire de
bordeaux
avait devancé son concurrent le plus
direct hedegaard fort de 17 voix les
candidats de l'opposition qu'à mon roi
pour le ps c'est maurice andrieux pour
le pc faisant le plein des suffrages de
leurs amis ce qui compte est la cause et
pis pour eux insuffisant pour l'emporter
à l'issue de ce premier tour donc il ya
peu près une heure suspension de
séance demandée par le président du
groupe rpr claude labbé
et après peut-être que l'interruption
on apprenait que le tenant du titre du
siège elle garforth retirée sa
candidature
il n'y avait donc pas pratiquement plus
de problèmes pour jacques charollais le
mas
qui sera donc
sans principes et luc au second tour à
la majorité absolue des suffrages
voilà donc la conclusion il ya quelques
minutes de cette fois l'après-midi de
l'assemblée
de cette première journée la 6ème
législature du régime
un beau début d'après-midi
482 députés deux absents des visages
sur lesquels il fallait mettre un an et
parfois un titre passé
dans la salle des quatre-colonnes des
journalistes par poignet regardant avec
nonchalance de remplacement des élus
semblables à ceux d'avant rien n'a
changé trop sans doute pour les jeunes
et nouveaux discret n'ayant pas encore
de compte dans nécessaire
c'était quelques minutes de rentrer un
peu près des rails de retrouvailles
source
enfin dans un bruit de tonnerre de
tambours le doyen
peu habitués aux usages de ce parlement
continue pourtant à treize anciens
titulaires sa présence était déjà
cet après-midi contestées par les
socialistes qui n'assistera pas à la
première audience
c'est une question de moralité
politique compte tenu des conditions
dans lesquelles
monsieur marcel dassault et le cumul ses
activités industrielles
pour l'aéronautique et ses fonctions
parlementaires et c'est aussi je le
répète en raison des conditions dans
lesquelles il a cru pouvoir conduire sa
campagne électorale grâce au moyen de
l'argent
fini les couloirs les élus des 12 et 19
mars derniers pénétrait enfin dans
l'hémicycle chacun à sa place par
ordre alphabétique le premier ministre
dit hier et de demain
si comme tout le monde raymond barre à
son bord et coutras le court et bien
terne discours du député d'assaut
le gouvernement a réussi à stabiliser
le franc
et même à l'améliorer
peu de poids
le taux d'intérêt elle est encore plus
élevé
pop et les industriels puissent investir
à l'aise c'est ce qu'a déclaré devant
un tel accord
une forêt d'europe à avoir recours
travailler avec le lancement par la loi
et cela n'a peut-être pas l'impôt de
solidarité
un grand écart pour le sport à la
portée d'une fois pour toutes
mais il sait qu'il est important
c'est que le produit de cet impôt
ne seraient pas versés au budget
général art
mais à une pièce
pérez partis a effectué 10
au mieux des intérêts de la france
les investissements de cette caisse
pour espérer que sa propriété
et s'il a élevé au grade de chevalier
à l'afp
un prix raisonnable
ainsi la france aura été le logo en
mesure d'avoir investi il ya dans
l'industrie
de faire repartir l'économie
aider à résorber le chômage
puis la petite lampe rouge celui partout
annonçant le scrutin des choses comme
ça commence à vraiment
toujours par deux fois le ticket à
bulletin secret chaque assiette le
géant australien 58' de 25 ans pilier
de découvrir des résultats du premier
tour
en l'état le plus
c'est même sans ça 183 points
les ciel et blanc par 136
monsieur pierre mansat sanglots
monsieur mario sera d'ailleurs éclatant
la suisse
aucun candidat n'ayant obtenu la
majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés
advienne que pourra le scrutin s'avère
nécessaire
elle m'a alors demandé un rassemblement
autour d'obama pour des missions de
maintien
edgar faure réfléchi il fait de même
les socialistes et les communistes aussi
depuis monsieur claude labbé à l'heure
actuelle
voilà pourquoi je tenais à le dire ce
que l'état
le souhaiterait
une suspension de séance qui pourrait
peut-être pas de 30 à 45 minutes en
tout cas cela demande
le dodo
après la suspension et une vive
discussion au sein du rpr edgar faure se
retire
nous allons procéder au deuxième plan
le scrutin
ford se retirer convient de dire que
mais sud assaut à 86 ans
alors des bonnes la journée n'est pas
terminée elle est sur le point de se
terminer et je crois qu'on peut dire que
dans cinq dix minutes on va voir le
résultat
je vous entends présent là-bas
mystère avant la course nous ne
l'aurons pas au plus tôt avant 8 heures
et demie
mais elle sait pas dire que chaque match
en face à faire un bon score car la
majorité de la prière
a décidé de voter pour lui ce sont les
députés de son groupe ils ont demandé
de se retirer pour daniel wu avait
beaucoup d'influencé l'assemblée s'il
espère ce soir avant leur avant la fin
du journal
chakra tout or à votre avis le plus fou
de nerfs père devrais-tu faire défaut
à monsieur charles massi
et non je vous ai dit que telle était
la majorité battront pour lui
pendant que une majorité absolue au
deuxième tour élections pour la
chambre le matin au score on peut
considérer c'est une défaite pour
jacques chirac oui et ça il est certain
que ce soir que m
nhl
le chirac
wyatte d'essuyer la première à chaque
personnel j'ai vécu jusqu'ici c'est une
assez grande gifle car il s'était
engagé à fond
dans cette affaire et il a laissé le
piège se refermer sur lui et à partir
de ce soir
du rpr n'est plus le banc le bloc
monolithique que nous connaissions cela
dit est-ce que le groupe va perdre son
unité pour autant
eh bien
je pense que oui et c'est ce que je
viens d'essayer de nous dire le groupe
était plus monolithique ce soir mais
monsieur chirac n'est pas un homme à
rester sur un échec et il va
certainement essayer de prendre sa
revanche et on peut estimer que la
cohabitation avec l'opposition qui
était souhaitée la recrue du tfc ne se
fera pas très facilement à
l'intérieur des commissions
c'est-à-dire que l'accession en pro
présidence et au bureau des commissions
pour l'opposition on a certainement en
pâtir alors là on arrive à
l'essentiel effectivement les relations
à l'intérêt de la majorité de tête
un petit peu d'erreurs non et bien oui
pas mal d'erreurs mais je pense que
monsieur bah on va en souffrir aussi car
la vigilance
sera renforcée du côté du rpr
mais ce qu'il faudra faire c'est
examiner avec beaucoup de d'intérêt
les résultats du premier tour car il
donne envie équilibre des forces à
l'intérieur de la majorité et oui en
quelque sorte le rééquilibrage or ces
ce rééquilibrage pour monsieur chirac
réglé car dans toute tentative
d'ouverture et les mois d'été
manoeuvre pour couper assez le rpr ou
pour leur acheter à droite
l'album à cirer le banc et je me charge
de cette dame mission dentelle et bien
monsieur dassault de nous donner les
résultats si possible avant les
etats-unis
enfin il convient de dire aussi que
l'élysée avait voulu dès la fin de
matinée précisé que cette réduction
ne concernait pas particulièrement la
présence de république et que toute
l'incarcération arbitraire sur sa
position dans cette affaire
et p sans fondement déclaration du
porte-parole de l'élysée
le bateau pour la politique qu'il est
d'abord du côté de la majorité les
travaux du conseil national du parti
républicain avec un double objectif
pour jean-pierre soisson son secrétaire
général
d'abord pour remporter son parti en
lançant une campagne d'adhésion et en
se fixant deux cent mille adhérents
d'ici à la fin de l'été
c'est-à-dire deux fois plus qu'à leurs
actes
et puis en développant le pr
jean-pierre soisson
entend bien s'engager dans la
construction du dr
l'union pour la démocratie française
du côté de l'opposition maintenant il
est essentiellement un débat qui se
développe à l'intérieur même des
rangs du parti communiste sur l'attitude
du pc pendant les élections
paris est plutôt une publication de la
fédération parisienne du parti affirme
que la discussion part en trombe
certains militants estiment même qu'il
faut en finir avec le langage de
l'auto-satisfaction
c'est un dossier sur lequel nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir en profondeur
demain ou après-demain
d'autant que tout à l'heure dans les
couloirs l'assemblée
georges marchais a dit que les tendances
étaient une visible au parti communiste
mais aucune tête notons bref
retenons aussi que eux le conseil
constitutionnel a fait ses comptes si il
est appelée à statuer sur la validité
du scrutin des 12 et 19 mars dans 50
circonscriptions
on pense que le contentieux sera réglé
avant l'été
une indication quant même en 20 ans
le conseil constitionnel a annulé
va-t-elle excluant des législatives
en marge des affaires sociales et
politiques et bien un certain agacement
dans les rapports cgt cfdt elles m'ont
maire a répondu aujourd'hui à la
lettre que lui avait adressé georges
seguy mercredi
la réponse est aussi dur que cet envoi
la cgt rim est le maire la cgt qui a
assis largement contribué à la
division de la gauche n'est pas bien
placée pour donner des leçons de
syndicalistes
et ce sera tout pour les affaires
intérieures
venons-en donc que l événement que
nous apprenions hier soir à la même
heure dans le journal la rencontre
giscard schmitz une rencontre demeurait
secrètes jusqu'à son achèvement
toute l'après-midi le président
français et le chancelier
ouest-allemand se sont entretenus au
château de rambouillet
a demandé à nouveau suite entretenu de
quoi et dieu très peu d'indications pas
de commentaire à l'elysée bonnet a
été un petit peu moins élevé
en faisant savoir que les deux hommes
n'ont examiné que les problèmes
planétaires il est vrai que ces
problèmes sont très aigu
à l'heure actuelle on a assisté
aujourd'hui encore à une nouvelle et
très forte chute du dollar surtout les
marchés
le franc lui et demeurer
explication de cette baisse du dollar
les très mauvais résultat du commerce
extérieur américain
mais ce retour demain à la maison
blanche le président carter va
s'attaquer at-il dit
au problème de l'inflation et de la
consommation excessive d'énergie les
deux causes principales selon lui de la
dégringolade du dollar
et le déficit extérieur américain
apparaît comme le responsable numéro
un de ses pairs les américains
achètent troupes à l'étranger
au pétrole
on y arriverait crevier quant à lui
l'après-midi
ou le streak la bourse de new york 5 m
le plus dense la chute du dollar le coup
d'où les marchés des changes
internationaux
certains experts estiment que les
etats-unis
robert gibbs toute l'europe
dans la bataille dans l'arc
de déclencher une crise économique et
les financières mondiale
regardez cette table pour la le terrain
perdu en un peu plus d'un an
par le dollar avec ces chiffres
il est facile de comprendre pourquoi les
produits allemands deviennent plus chers
que ceux mais depuis ni les soeurs et
pourquoi les touristes américains n'ont
plus envie d'aller passer leurs vacances
en suisse le dollar
l'eau
arbre complet ici depuis la fin 2009 176
acheter ou louer
davantage de produits disent les
américains ou japonais afin de nous
aider à l'équilibré de notre balance
commerciale
à travers la baisse du dollar c'est une
guerre du pacifique économique qui
s'est couvert
mais valéry giscard d estaing et
boutiques n'ont pas dû parler que du
dollar ils se sont concertés à
quelques jours du sommet européen de
tata nano vendredi et samedi
et puis peut-être le chancelier
ouest-allemand at-il fait part au
président alfred français par dans le
des problèmes que connaît sa santé
icis problèmes sociaux socialement
de fait on a remarqué que l'allemagne
en ce moment
s'adresser un peu moins qu'auparavant
à l'inflation
et beaucoup plus aux chômeurs
des mines ouvertement décidé mais une
certaine impatience tout de même
près de 120 milles métallos allemands
ont cessé le travail depuis plus de
trois semaines
les principales firmes de la
métallurgie sont touchés
ce mouvement touche en effet le
bade-würtemberg 22e région
métallurgique allemand
excellent hortefeux financièrement et
partant des cotisations syndicales que
nous avons versé on peut tenir encore
longtemps
nous 17 février pour qui les syndicats
ont suffisamment d'argent pour payer les
grévistes et contraindre les patrons à
ses dettes
de fait et c'est plutôt nouveau dans
l'allemagne de l'après-guerre
les syndicats d'autres rahmani testé
cette année une fermeté et une
endurance tout à fait exceptionnelle
point de pourcentage d'augmentation de
salaire que de garanties à long terme
de l'emploi en allemagne fédérale
ces morts que je pouvais pas aider ce
syndicaliste confirme son refus de faire
plus longtemps les frais d'un processus
de rationalisation industrielle qui va
se poursuivre dans la prochaine
décennie d'action
il s'agit pour lui de contrôler cette
évolution pour ne pas transformer les
ouvriers qualifiés en assistés sociaux
il conclut sans concession à ce sujet
nous ne céderons pas
à cette fermeté syndical les chefs
d'entreprises allemands ont répondu par
les locaux la fermeture pure et simple
des usines
pratiquement la moitié de la production
métallurgique est à l'arrêt
cette paralysie provoquée sur mac
technique dans les régions et les
usines encore en activité un compromis
restait possible malgré l'enjeu de
cette lutte
pour un patronat allemand qui travaille
pour sa compétitivité
pour le patron allemand
c'est une question de rentabilité
énorme pour le prochain printemps
cette rentabilité était égal
à des rationalisations serrar summerlea
séance sans suivi
forcément par des pertes des
qualifications et certes d'emplois
c'est pour ça
syndicat réfute et c'est pour ça
patron insiste parce que pour les
partants c'est une question
compétition sur les marché mondial qui
deviennent de plus en plus dur
les syndicalistes les allemands ne sont
pas insensibles à ces arguments
malgré leur réputation de sagesse et
de modération ils entendent cependant
contraindre le patronat la révision
d'une politique économique
ceux qui privilégient la machine par
rapport à l'euro
c'est là un débat qui dépasse les
frontières de l'allemagne fédérale
outre-rhin
il a déjà passablement altéré un
concensus sociale ce qui vu de
l'extérieur par lasser à toute
épreuve
voilà monsieur dassault a bien fait les
choses comme promis il va maintenant
nous donner les résultats ou en tout
cas fallait faire donné par daniel
evans en quelques secondes danielle vous
avez des résultats je crois oui mais ce
sont des résultats officieux c'est un
beau score
266 voix
mais ils ne seront proclamés qualité
péniche dans la corbeille à la valeur
de 137 à fait à 30 de plus que la
majorité absolue mais 15 de moins que
l'ensemble ce que la majorité pourrait
obtenir de jouer c'est pas assez c'est
quand même un petit déchire
bien mais c'est sa voix belle masse et
donc à parler de ce soit président de
l'assemblée nationale
belgique maintenant le baron brard te
l'enlever un mois après le baron empain
est peut-être mort c'est en tout cas ce
faire firmin quotidien anversois qui
fait état d'un coup de téléphone
anonyme
il rend maintenant pour la huitième
journée consécutive plusieurs villes
du pays on été le théâtre hier de
manifestation violente de manifestations
contre le régime
et j'apprends à l'instant t il ya même
pas mort
à l'issue de ces manifestations dans la
nuit de dimanche à lundi
et il est vrai que faute d' image faute
de photos
eh bien on a un peu trop tendance quand
on évoque l'iran à ne parler que du
chat et de sa famille
et pas assez d'une opposition qui est
très rarement je pense qu'un
d'ailleurs nous venons d'apprendre
également que le shah d'iran qui était
en vacances vient de rentrer atterrant
en catastrophe et dont il faut dire que
situation est assez grave en vérité
oui ou non on assista
une véritable vague insurrectionnelle
qui déferle actuellement sur les rangs
rp ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il y
a semble-t-il à convergence de trois
oppositions
l'opposition de gauche marxiste et
opposition disant libérale nationaliste
et l'opposition
islamique buropro dirait de droite où
les chiites
alors ç'a commencé vous en souvenez
sans doute lorsque le présentateur a
été
à téhéran il ya eu des manifestations
étudiante une répression des morts et
puis ça s'est tendue dans certaines
villes en particulier
dans une ville s'appelle à vide comme
qu'est une ville religieux
le six morts officiellement une
opposition digne plusieurs dizaines
étrange iran les cantines ya comme cela
ça tombe de mort
les mots le deuil dur une quarantaine de
jours selon la loi chiite
alors au bout de 40 jours de deuil il ya
eu des manifestations en l'honneur des
morts de com et ça a fait de nouvelles
émeutes et en particulier dans la ville
de tabriz qui est la deuxième ville du
pays il a eu des dizaines de morts
et cela fait quarante jours
ce qui fait que tout le monde assiste à
une nouvelle vague
pourquoi si vous laissez les morts et
les victimes de tabriz et là c'est un
peu près déjà saisi le ils ont été
secoués par les notes et puis je crois
qu'il faut signaler c'étaient des
métiers s'en prennent systématiquement
au grand coeur
pour l'heure au siège du parti unique
à tout ce qui représente le pouvoir
mais aussi
à tout ce qui est luxueux tout ce qui
est cinéma arrêts et l'hôtel
mais il faut dire aussi que c'est pas si
facile de s'exprimer pour un opposant
dans un pays où la police politique et
tony présente
oui d'ailleurs les français placent
s'imagine mal ce pc
que s'opposer à un régime totalitaire
qui soient de droite et de gauche
je veux vous rappeler vous vous souvenez
antenne 2 nous avions diffusé
l'interview dan iranien
qui nous révéler
qu'il avait été payé par la police
secrète iranienne la savak pourquoi
assassiné
les opposants politiques un en france et
en suisse oui et non
à ce moment-là on vous appelle
nettement trop proprette mardi
quitte à l'association
organise son blog social
l'organisation nationale
leur donner les moyens de passer pas du
tout
dans les deux sens la suède
de son côté l'euro reste stable face
à l'euro à 1 6 euro ce n'est pas
seulement question de l'équité de
cette consultation
à challans
il fallait tuer quelqu'un d'autre la
comble que ce programme monde bout de
l'ipo numéro 1 pour le numéro 2 il est
hautement
évidemment ça pour que je pense que
les tensions
mais il faut prendre les choses à notre
manière parce que je fasse personal
ajusté de neige après trimestre
qu'est-ce qu'il ya à dire
d'ailleurs dans le temps des fêtes
la séance avait pourtant été
annoncée
ça c'est trop c'est le silence et le
secret cependant jamais
quand même le fait est que sur ses
coûts pour ceux qui ne le savent bien
ce que c'est qu'une arme pour marcher
silencieusement sans salaire
je pense que beaucoup de sang
me faire venir
la caserne
pour les spécialistes indépendants ont
également signé un an nous aurons une
saison
vous avez donc que vous souvenez dans
l'accès ci-dessus témoignages et
documents que nous avions diffusé
cet homme cet homme s'était pas un ange
c'est pour ça qu'on l'avait choisi pour
pour commettre un crime politique il
avait dans sa vie beaucoup de choses à
se reprocher mais là à la fin de sa
vie
il a vu
un sursaut
un sursaut formidable idée
il nous le disait d'ailleurs lire mon
âge non je ne peux pas faire ça
alors il a été voir ce qu'ils avaient
assassiné qu'il connaissait il aura dit
voilà c'est pourquoi on va payer il a
prévenu la police française il a
prévenu la presse l'information
et bien cet homme là lorsqu'il faisait
des choses peu recommandable
il était très riche
ma chérie tu disais bien
et d'un seul coup
au moment où il existe sursaut de
conscience a été le gouffre
la solitude
naturellement le l'état iranien le
craquant le surveillant
l'état français ne voulant pas être
mêlés dans cette affaire peut-être à
cause des liens économiques avec l'iran
l'opposition se méfieront de lui il a
vécu des mois de misère que vous ne
pouvez pas imaginer d'abondantes il est
mort il ya une semaine il est mort
presque de faim presque de misère sans
rien
il n'y avait plus rien pour payer son
hôtel
et on a failli le mettre
à la fosse commune car non seulement il
avait rien pour payer
les soins qu'il a manqué les moyens
pour payer son enterrement
ce matin
il a été enterré
parce que quelques personnes se sont
cotisés
il y avait autour de sa tombe
10 onze personnes pas plus
donc trois journalistes
je crois que c'est une chose
une information que nous avons apprise
il ya moins de deux heures leur ado du
célèbre navigateur norvégien thor
heyerdahl a été complètement détruit
par le tremblement
feu à une dizaine de kilomètres de de
djibouti litoria redal l'homme dit-on
kitty il venait de gagner son pari
rejoindre à l'aide d'un radeau un
radeau en roseau le froid intense à
karachi puis karachi addictif
et puis cette information aux
frontières des arrêts de la diplomatie
la fin de la collaboration entre
l'opéra de paris élue à la cesse
la fère couvait depuis un moment à la
suite de la coalition qui avait été
fait au metteur en scène soviétique le
dubbi meuf
de venir à paris monter sa version de
la dame de pique la dame de pique de
tchaïkovski
d'après twitchfilm net
six cent mille francs de pertes pour
l'opéra
les artistes étaient engagés les
décors construits vous enverrez la
maquette dans une minute mais tout de
suite la colère de nombreux pays
émergents sont absolument
dégueulasse je dois dire je ne peux n'y
a pas d'autre mot
aujourd'hui si dans la maison de son
côté est en hausse cette décision
doit être prise il était allé
dans la ville de lévis
pendant que les libraires je n'étais
pas là
pauvre regardez cette partition et il
sera en conséquence
en vitrine
il n'est pas la côte d'or dans la
vieille ville en cumul les autres propos
de windows ok semaine ce qui est élu
morts
davos a retoqué rallye le patrimoine au
musée site c'était un grand changement
des scènes en coupe en faisant des
coupures
ce qui est tout à fait normal on
retrouve même dans des opéras de
mozart au cou
de temps en temps des scènes
ça ne peut pas être madame de
qui fait état de plus de tireurs toro
personne dans ce pays
de la paix la réalisation à l'opéra
de paris ça doit être
une part d'une politique nouvelle
6 elle se présente maintenant
à la fin une bonne fois pour toutes
maintenant des feuilletons de
l'assemblée c'est la confirmation de ce
que nous vous disions en début de
journal et de ce que les
mais c'est sur la masse des biens et du
président nous écoutons chez dassault
m
cette offre deux-cents sion de cette
voie je pense que vous l'avez entendu
comme moi en ce moment à jacques chaban
delmas c'est en train de bouleverser ses
collègues
la marée noire maintenant voilà
maintenant que les bretons doit faire
face à une autre marée plus
sympathique mais parfois un petit peu
plus brouillonne celle des volontaires
qui souhaitent
si les aider pour le nettoyer les plages
parce que la plupart des plages
maintenant le pompage du plus gros est
terminée il faut maintenant place à la
pelle au saut tout raté ce à quoi il
faut ajouter à l'instar d'hans 510 pour
les rochers
pour le seul département du finistère
on a recensé sept mille cinq cents
jeunes appartenant à des groupes bien
structuré
imaginez donc que ce que cela donne si
l'on ajoute toutes les bonnes volontés
qui se propose de manière un petit peu
anarchique sans avoir résolu leur
problème de restauration et
d'hébergement eyi si vous n'imaginez
pas voit son but pour vous jean-marc
kilos et en régaler
m
sous le soleil une première impression
bien trompeuses
pour les volontaires de la marée noire
un énorme
détail près
l'épave de l'amoco cadiz
pour limiter les conséquences du
péché 7000 hommes de troupe et
peut-être une volontaire sont déjà
sur place
voici une soixantaine de jeunes
volontaires venus de bruxelles ou de
louvain ils se sont sommairement
s'installer après on pense
imprévoyance mauvaise coordination où
il a fallu improviser pour les héberger
la jeunesse et des sports a pu parer au
plus pressé
mais l'adjoint au maire de port salle
débordés de travail regretté de ne
pas pouvoir pour l'instant retenu les
accusations
il savait explicite
l'hébergement en battant andy et le
reste assurée la nourriture aussi bien
qui va les encadrer demain
ces équipements
sont-ce les autorités ils sont ce les
militaires je ne sais pas pour l'instant
tous ces groupes militaires équipements
sont parfaitement 3 cadrés
et moi ce qui me fait le plus de peine
ce que je viens ici avec tout leur
courage à toute l'europe
et qu'on ne puisse rien leur donner un
frère
sinon d'ordonner une pelle et un saut
son nom l'indiqué un endroit ils
doivent aller
car en maints endroits de la côte la
tâche la plus urgente est toujours de
pomper
on paie à marée haute et nettoyée au
jet à marée basse
pour évacuer le maximum de pétrole
avant la prochaine grande marée le 6
avril
ils sont bien organisés les volontaires
pourront être alors très utile pour
détecter plage des rochers pour le
nettoyage en finale
mais pour le moment
la bonne volonté il ne suffit pas
moi je suis un peu
un peu trop bossekota mon groupe mais
par la suite ils ont fait preuve de
beaucoup de gens
et pour cent
je ne sais que je me suis dit qu'il y
avait
plus à faire ici on est ici pour
vivre la marée noire à tous les
niveaux au niveau du travail parce que
c'est intéressant quand même mais
aussi à se rendre compte de toutes les
incapacités au niveau technique qu'au
niveau
l'organisation est aussi de tous les
problèmes que cela pose
comme dans le finistère
depuis lors les plateformes
gros des troupes les premiers bataillons
de volontaires plus d'un milliard
cela peut se comprendre en belgique des
associations de protection de la nature
les amis de la terre en particulier sont
très actifs
de plus la télévision belge les radios
ont lancé de nombreux appels pour
inciter leurs auditeurs à venir sur les
côtes bretonnes
vous trouvez ça devient lassant passa
passa pas comme ça quoi
avon
on n'imagine pas ce à quoi
promettant de gesté hier matin quand on
a mis les pieds dans la complice de
cette aide
franchement dégueulasse et chaud
elle aurait dû prévoir c'est un petit
peu
pour une fois les gendarmes laissent pas
trop s'en rendre compte maintenant quand
on voit à la télévision japonaise
pour rendre complètement différente
il s'agit pour eux c'est comme ça
les maires des communes sinistrées
craignent tous d'être débordé par
cette marée de volontaires une réunion
s'est tenue à lannion cet après-midi
pour recenser les besoins des communes
et surtout leur capacité d'hébergement
nos confrères l'équipement dans
certaines villes
pour ces jeunes belges c'est un peu la
déception certains auraient voulu
pouvoir ramasser du mazout dans la
minute suivant leur arrivée
et on est arrivé ici accord aura pas de
terrain suédois peu importe
ça s'est arrangé par après parce que
on va trouver ou
où loger aujourd'hui face à cette
affaire pour manger et surtout cet
important
le maire
on présentera ce matin j'ai demandé à
ses pieds parce que jean-marc parent
brady a pas assez de matériel pour
passer de la période
alors on laisse trop faire passer la tva
lui appartenant
cette sympathique mais encombrante
marais de volontaires s'organise peu à
peu même si le travail ne manque pas
et à contempler ces grèves de polluer
on se demande si tout sera nettoyé en
bretagne pour l'été
le mazout est partout sur les zones
touchées il n'a rien épargné pas
même le petit cimetière marin de
saint-michel-en-grève près de lannion
il n'en existe que deux en france
dire 17 fois ce qu'on voit à la
télévision et ce qu'on voit ici c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose alors
noël mamère
je crois qu'il faut rappeler quelques
conseils
oui effectivement tous les volontaires
colonel ville de morlaix belgique parce
qu'ils ne se sont pas adressé
directement à l'ambassade de france en
belgique
mais pour tous ceux qui veulent partir
en bretagne leur conseillons et nous
leur avons déjà dit à plusieurs
reprises
de s'adresser à la direction
départementale de la jeunesse et des
sports de leur lieu de résidence à
cause de la condition des soies groupé
prendre de plus de 30 personnes avec un
âge minimum de 17 ans et c'est très
important
l'accord pourrait quand même au passage
salué le texte
auteur belge ils sont nombreux et c'est
par centaines vous l'avez vu qu'ils sont
venus sur les plages bretonnes aider des
gens qui n'ont pas la même nationalité
que j'espère que la réciproque saurait
le cas échéant possible
alors autre problème pour les bretons
et les vents ont tourné et soufflent
maintenant de lester ont tendance à
souiller décrit
qui ne l'étaient pas jusqu'à la
plusieurs manifestations se sont
déroulées en bretagne durant les
dernières 48 heures en signe de
protestation plusieurs milliers de
personnes à morlaix alors que ryan st
brieuc saint-malo et bresse
reste le plus important des points de
rassemblement
à l'appel des syndicats des partis de
gauche
michel rocard était venue à brest mais
n'a pas participé au défilé
françois mitterrand viendra de marbre
le poids la tenant sur les inondations
la situation s'améliore un peu en
région parisienne mais les riverains de
la scène de la marne et du lointain
regarde toujours le ciel
et les autres avec inquiétude
la seine la marne et le loiret
les trois principales rivières en crue
dans le bassin parisien
sont devenus depuis hier moins
menaçante pour les livres
la décrue
est amorcé
même si les écarts sont encore
inondées les routes coupées et
quelques pavillons isolé
les records sont bleues bien avoir été
battu
et dimanche
en particulier par le lointain
qui en est à sa 4e tenue depuis le
début de l'année
mais j'ai une question préoccupe ceux
qui ont les pieds dans l'eau la pluie
doit-elle continuer de tomber
les agriculteurs notamment craignent que
les inondations menace les engrais et
les prochaines semaines
au sein de notre part
il ya aujourd'hui par exemple dégagé
un petit peu
mais ce qui est important
blanc 949 entendu ces paroles
récolte pourrait être menacée
le bloc québécois
thomas femmes avait ouvert la marque
qui va de l'avant la banque attend au
tournant
finalement cette offre d'emploi
c'est ça ma mère par contre la
pandémie
le déploiement dans le tableau
une fois de plus qu'on se pose cette
question
les barrages en amont de paris où
est-il éviter de telles inondations
abidjan est totalement grind
on remarquait de musset et fruits et en
anglais les crêtes
mais on ne la supprime pas complètement
c'était un pari s'il est très bas âge
se traduit comment le sillon au cours de
la crue
colombière de vivre s'il n'avait pas eu
le barack obama ont pris part à ce
salon
les comptes observé à paris par
rapport à cette crue aurait été
supérieure de quelque 50% de
centimètres à propos de ces barrages
on a mis en cause leur nombre
insuffisant
je crois que il ne le membre des
baraques choses et surtout leur
capacité
et le facteur déterminant parce que il
s'agit comme je disais tout à l'heure
dans le magazine et de grandes
quantités d'eau
et pour un magazine de grandes
quantités d'eau il s'agit de trouver
des sites bien choisi
et quand on pense aux difficultés que
l'on rencontre pourquoi
étudier à un barrage sur un site
donné si on voulait le multiplier sur
un grand nombre de sites
on ne ferait qu'accroître ses
difficultés
un peu partout que ce soit au bord de
l'eau
un il sur l'indicateur de niveau
plus inquiétant
sur la météo
via la météo et de demain je peux dire
quand même que la suisse s'est
améliorée aujourd'hui car il a fait
relativement beau alors demain le temps
sera très brumeux le matin avec des
éclaircies dans l'après-midi
et les nuages resteront abondant sur les
côtes de la manche inaugurale du soleil
dans le midi
voilà je reviens à l'information
essentielle de ce journal que nous avons
appris d'ailleurs là que nous avons
apprises pendant ce journal l'élection
de jacques chaban delmas se chargeant
dans la masse
il nous a fait l'amitié de venir avec
nous aussitôt son élection
monsieur le premier ministre je vous
félicite d'abord
je pense que vous ne pouvez pas
m'entendre et que c'est daniel brême
qui va vous poser des questions
et bien non je ne pose pas de questions
car monsieur chaban delmas sera de faire
une déclaration inexacte en question
allons bon la parenté vous avez la
parole
l'assemblée nationale
constitue l'un des rouages essentiels
de nos institutions
et j'ai désiré la présider
pour veiller directement
et personnellement
à son bon fonctionnement
c'est un travail que je connais
pour l'avoir déjà fait pendant
toute la durée
de la présence du général de gaule à
l'élysée
si j'y reviens dans le même esprit
celui
qui fait reposer
les relations humaines
sur la droite
le respect mutuel
et la tolérance
ces principes essentiels à toute vie en
société
doivent s'appliquer à l'assemblée
nationale comme ailleurs
et l'assemblée nationale doit être
exemplaire à cet égard
je m'y emploierai du monde
et en pensant spécialement
à la jeunesse
qui nous regardent
et qui nous juger
même après un affrontement 6 rue de
l'apaisement ne va pas être très
facile fermé depuis lundi dernier dans
le classement hormis ce classement
à l'heure actuelle
ce journal est à présent terminée il
les acteurs 36 jours merci d'avoir suivi
patrick le comme présentera la
dernière édition aux alentours de 23
heures je souhaite à tous une très
très bonne soirée
mer
pères